name and outlet and then we can begin
okay
i'm ready to do this for greg
alba john humphrey the real rejects
we are very excited to be here i love
this interview already
oh god this is what we were hoping for
it was like the clerks
thank you what's going on reject nation
greg here
john we are going to watch the trailer
for snake eyes here's the reality of the
situation of when we're shooting this it
is actually
may 11th we have an interview to do with
henry golding who's playing snake eyes
in about 15 minutes from now what they
did was the first time ever in real
rejects history they offered to send
over the trailer to us
in advance we're going to react to the
trailer because i told the person over
at paramount
that we are very particular about making
sure that when we do a reaction it's the
first time we recover and then
we really are particular about that and
afterwards you know it's supposed to be
like a five minute interview
so we'll show you guys the interview
right after this reaction
there's chapters in it if you want in
this video if you want to skip to it
anywho let's watch the trailer for snake
eyes and see what's going on
cool
for 600 years
the journey from here
no that's samara weaving yeah
scarlet whoa
cool
not bad oh it snapped
look guys we've had a lot of issues with
music companies claiming us lately so
you know if the music's up and down
you know why it's a short teaser trailer
from what they showed us like the images
that we're getting here are really
emphasizing the kind of action that they
have here
i didn't realize that they have the
actor here from warrior is he playing
storm
shadow he is playing storm shadow okay
cool andrew koji in here ecowise is the
hard master
damn oh that's gonna be wrapped up
samara weaving and here is scarlet
awesome it's a cool cast for me my
association i think a lot of people too
have with gi joe snake eyes is a fan
favorite oh
some people are like i mainly show up
for snake guys and storm shadow
those are the main people you show for
so to get like your own dedicated movie
for it just makes a lot of sense to me
and henry golding is an awesome actor so
we are excited to like get a chance to
talk with him i saw that interview we
did on jimmy fallon a few months ago and
you see the training that he's
done for this and man is he like it is
awesome
yeah some stuff and it's on display here
i mean you gotta work with these actors
we're talented ass martial artists
and so you you really want to make sure
you you're on par
one concern of mine is it's not really a
big concern but it is
like snake eyes is so mysterious of a
character like he's such an uneven talk
no he's like so mysterious that to now
literally pull off the mask really get
to know him will he have like a name
in this movie will it enhance the
character to get to know him or will it
kind of detract you've gotten
into a storm shadow a lot and then snake
eyes is the one you don't really know as
well but snake guys is
usually the favorite because it's just
the coolest you know yeah you know the
badass origin tale but as a character i
mean part of the allure is that he is
incredibly competent with various
weapons and martial arts and is also
yeah just like the silent badass it
makes a lot of sense they would want to
get an
actor like henry golding to bring this
character to more personable life but it
does
yeah make me wonder what the approach is
gonna be is he gonna talk
but not a lot or something like that by
the end of the movie is he going to
become the silent warrior like
it raises a lot of questions because
yeah this character at least from
from the research i've done has been
like classified in his origins for like
the kind of
whole run of the character and the
action figures and the cartoons and all
that it's kind of the charm
so it does seem like a big risk but also
a big opportunity
i mean there's like little bits that
you've gotten of his backstory you are
gonna dive more into the details here
but yeah i am wondering if it's gonna be
more like a body language role it'd be
like a tarantino movie
yeah looks like a fun action movie and i
feel like henry golding will deliver the
goods i'm not just saying that if you're
like a real loyal follower of this
channel i've said a few times that i
feel like he could play superman
so yeah yeah absolutely i felt like when
they want to cast an asian superman he's
the guy to go to i have faith in it
snake i
stole the show and she had your
retaliation and this is like a complete
reboot so let's see what they got in
store man what do you guys think of the
trailer leave your thoughts down below
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell and hey
here's the interview that we did with
henry golding it's only like five
minutes long
we don't know what we say hopefully it
went all right let's go
i love this interview already okay this
is what we're hoping for
it was like the clerks thank you
yeah that's exactly with the coffee room
i'll remain silent for the rest
we don't change for any press junket oh
i guess i'm jay
i don't know i'm both i gotta start off
by saying this
uh my fiance and i love the hell out of
you so my fiancee doesn't really love
that many actors but she like really
loves
it i've said a couple of times on our
youtube channel
i'm like if they ever do an asian
superman it should be henry golding i
know you got the snake guys thing going
but
i think you'd be a great superman oh
amazing i mean i can see
i can see you guys the huge fans of
comic book
uh fun and is that a rick t-shirt and a
godzilla and daredevil
everything screams like superfans so i
apprec i appreciate the
love i can't wait for you guys to get
hold of this this movie
i mean we're excited we'll tear this
whole wall down and just make it all gi
joe
the marketing team said this would look
good but when snake eyes dropped yes
i'm gonna keep it to you we saw the
trailer for this
it looks awesome oh you did yeah you're
like one of the
very rare people who have had the chance
to see it illegally sent to us they
shouldn't have done it
but uh watching this a question did come
to mind snake eyes origin is just so
damn mysterious
and i'm trying to i'm trying to use like
some actor lingo here and maybe you can
help me fill in the blank
i was wondering like what's creating his
backstory here since
i know you can't reveal too much about
the plot is what would you say like
for developing snake guys what his like
core memory or core wound or like base
human emotion might
be for this guy so we can get a sense of
who this guy is internally
man that's that's a tough one without
giving away too much
before answering your question i think
we need to go back to what we're doing
with
this snake eyes of this universe and
this is a complete reboot
of gi joe and we're bringing the
origin story of senkai's the the man
behind the mask the man behind the
weapon
before the weapon before the suit before
everything
who he is as a human as me and you
like he's a guy with faults he's a guy
with dreams that have been crushed
challenges that he has to overcome and
so he's a broken
person he's a broken human in the
beginning of the story when we first
meet him
and he makes them really really bad
decisions
which follow him through the entire
movie
but we see the turnaround like we all
deserve
the second chances in life and we see
his switch
his alignment to who he truly
needs to become and that's the snake
eyes we love dearly
um so it's seeing that from the ground
up
from the sewer that he emerges from
to who he becomes so i feel like you i
feel like you answered it
you didn't answer it
but i think that's the best i can give
you without giving away too much
i i feel like you answered it thank you
i mean it's a great you're really gonna
get to know this character it's awesome
in addition to the trailer i mean we
also saw that uh you know badass
training reel that you played on fallon
did you have like a particular favorite
weapon to use or was there a particular
set piece that you're excited for people
to see especially
i mean to be honest it was it was the
katana work uh
we had the phenomenal choreographer
kenji
takagaki uh if i'm pronouncing his name
right tani tanigaki
sorry he did i don't i'm sure you've
seen it raroni kenshin
if you haven't i'm going to virtually
punch you in the face guys
have you have you seen it definitely
yes if you haven't
watch it the latest movie is coming out
and
it is some of the best cinematic sword
work
ever created okay it's based on the
anime so you'll you'll love it raroni
kenshin
he was our core choreographer and
martial artist so we went through this
boot camp
of of two months every single one of the
actors went through it for their
perspective roles
and of course snake eyes needed to
master the the katana
of course absolutely and so you see his
progression you see him
make the mistakes you see him get beat
up that's that's what we love about this
movie is that like
he's not some superhero awesome he's
he's a guy
who's worked hard to get what he what he
has so yeah we
we see morning light morning light is
his weapon of choice
in which that's all will be discovered
and explained
i love this they are really going to
flush him out i know we got like maybe
five seconds left i gotta ask this quick
question
yeah snake eyes generally doesn't have a
real name
in this movie will we learn his real
name or did you as an
actor have a real name in mind for him
if we don't learn it in this movie
do you think i'm going to give that away
i just want to know if you know how to
get to that
scoop i don't know if you know it need
that scoop his name's burt
i had a feeling it was a bert this whole
time
daniels i've given it away damn it
paramount's going to kill me that asian
snake
is a bird a wider name than alaska
[Laughter]
it's one of those things that is is
mysterious and and before we we got to
this
point in in this uh creation of of this
particular gi joe universe we didn't
know
what he looked like behind the mask
right there's going to be many things
that we discover
and having larry hammer as executive
producer
we have the right to be able to
create yeah with him the character that
he
always wanted to create you know perhaps
back in the
day he was ruled under an iron thumb
perhaps we don't know but like we we
definitely
uh went to larry and was like what can
we do with this character that keeps
truthful
to the core origin and the story but at
the same time
open the doors for new fans and the new
universe
in which we want to grow gotcha
you know how to sell a sizzle thank you
henry for your time
this was awesome thank you so much this
is great take care
feel free to punch us in the face
[Music]